a Seth MacFarlane movie about a talking
teddy bear
my buddy bumble lion could see this now
you guys have no idea what that is do
you died no okay Ted so Ted stars Mark
Wahlberg Mila Kunis and Seth MacFarlane
as the voice of Ted and it's also
directed by Seth MacFarlane so the story
is when Mark Wahlberg's character was a
little kid in the 80s he wished that his
teddy bear was alive so he can be his
best friend and then he came alive now
it's like 27 years later so they're both
adults and they're they're lizards it's
not putting it nicely or anything like
that they're they're pretty deadbeat and
he's been dating Mila Kunis for four
years who wants to take it to the next
level she wants to be engaged or
whatever and she's like can you have Ted
move out now this is where the movie
actually surprised me and did it really
well because the concept is his friend
is a little teddy bear so you'd be like
all right teddy bear or Mila Kunis Mila
Kunis twins tell the bear to piss off
but you can't help but see Ted as his
friend not just as teddy bear
Ted's a person so you understand that
Mark Wahlberg like he's my friend I
don't want him to move out and surprise
me it could just fell flat on his face
and I've been like I don't get it
tell the bear to go away it's Mila Kunis
yeah Mila Kunis continues to be one of
the hottest chicks breathing and not yea
that's alive or dead not not that I dig
dead chicks it's snow and I'm mantids
it's just one of the hottest chicks ever
she's pretty ridiculous in this movie
and she's actually pretty cool for a
chick who's trying to get a guy to tell
his teddy bear to piss off you do see
where she's coming from
Ted is holding Mark Wahlberg back not
like Ted's like the most positive
influence on his life is like hey you
don't smoke pot and you have a good job
because of me buddy that's it's really
the opposite of that entirely so Seth
MacFarlane's responsible for bringing us
Family Guy and a few other cartoons that
aren't really family got it no one
really gives a [ __ ] about it so Family
Guy and I was kind of worried about the
movie Ted because I find one of the
funniest things about Family Guy is the
fact that it pushes the limits of TV I
mean really you're like can they do that
on TV that's just funny that they did
but in a movie there are very few limits
that you can't cross so you're like he
has no limit so what'll be funny in this
will it be funny it was really funny
a lot of pop-culture references a lot of
movie references a lot of 80s references
I really liked all of that it was great
I love that kind of humor there's some
[ __ ] that Ted says you're like this is
one of the best characters ever it
really is although he is the identical
voice of Peter Griffin kind of funny one
of the funniest lines in the trail
when he's with the four hookers isn't
even in the movie you know when he's all
like I swear to God her name's shoving
young bloggers show he Chevron K ID I
laughed my ass off in the trailer the
line wasn't even in the movie the
situation was in the movie but not that
line it makes you wonder why but this
movie was funny I was laughing my ass
off in the intro of the movie and I
laughed all the way to the credits the
credits were even funny there are a few
fart jokes in the movie they're like
alright ones okay two or three what for
so I was like those kind of jokes are
put into a movie when the writer can't
think of anything funny you can see just
like I can tell something funny supposed
to go here I can't think of it a dead
fart joke maybe they'll give me a solid
B for trying I kind of do I guess it's
just like it's the lowbrow humor in this
movie although there's not a lot of
highbrow humor but the movies funny as
hell if you like Family Guy you'll love
it even if you don't you'll probably
like it you know people like I hate
Family Guy they will laugh in this movie
and hate the fact they did I will say
I'm going to buy this movie on blu-ray
hilarious is hell I'm getting my friend
to watch this movies it's funny so this
is definitely one of the funniest movies
of the year easily what is your favorite
comedy of the year whatever it is
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you